our shout out tonight for an unusual
collaboration between an artist in
Brooklyn working to honor a brave
journalist James Foley was 40 years old
when his career as a war zone photo
journalist was tragically and brutally
cut short too awful tragic news from
overseas late today it's about an
American journalist named James Foley
beheaded by members of the violent
Islamic group Isis he reported from
dangerous places bearing witness to the
lives of people a world away now almost
five years later an artist in Brooklyn
Bradley McCollum has made it his mission
to let the world finally see the work
that James Foley risk his life to create
when you searched his name all you would
find were the evidences of his execution
and it did seem to sort of brant
emboldened the executioner but did
little to tell his story
so with the permission of James Foley's
mother Diane
but Colin began to go through the video
and still photos that James had left
behind in his backpack that had never
been seen publicly and inside the
backpack for these five hard drives and
his old computer and at that point this
project became very personal using an
industrial-sized printer McCollum first
creates a silk overlay of the images he
has selected and then places the printed
fabric over a canvas painting he is made
of one of the scenes Foley captured with
his camera so for me this becomes this
moment of
almost like Christmas well the painting
behind me is one of my favorite
paintings in this series and it really
combines two images it's capturing what
I really think of is the kind of this
moment of beauty within a place of
absolute destruction and kind of ruins
and overlaying this oil painting of the
landscape is a detailed scan and
reprinting of a letter that Jim wrote
another one taken in Libya during the
overthrow of the Libyan leader Kadafi
what you see in the painting is a whole
series of rebel soldiers with their cell
phone cameras taking an image of this
fallen soldier we know now that is
Qaddafi's son dozens of images photos of
war turned into art for me it's not
important that you understand the sub
narratives I think as a painting it
begins to speak universally to to war
and conflict and accountability before
being taken hostage by Isis Foley had
earlier been held hostage by a group in
Libya which ultimately let him go but
not before putting him through a true
test of his courage I jumped up tried to
say we were journalists then I was hit
several times with lot of ak-47 punched
and dragged into a vehicle with my hands
tied behind my back
for Bradley McCollum there is a heavy
responsibility
to get it right and it is a
responsibility it's a responsibility to
to create work that both honors and and
takes the next step beyond simply being
a memorial but one that transforms and
makes us think in a much broader sense
so it is a tribute to his journalism oh
absolutely
yeah absolutely none of these paintings
would exist if Jim wasn't as committed
to telling the stories he told I'm not
using anyone elses images I'm looking at
and thinking about and making selections
based on the footage he took in a way it
feels often like I'm collaborating with
Jim and so our shout out tonight -
Bradley McCallum whose works of art
bring new life to the heroic journalism
of James Foley that's our program for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you back here next week